اذن تحضير امريكيا واضح من نفوذ الصين
وروسيا في فناءها الخلفي امريكا اللاتينيه
بما لها من ثروات ضخمه وموقع الاستراتيجي
لكن المنافسه الصعبه والمحور الصيني
الروسي يتغلغل يوما بعد اخر الرئيس
الفنزويلي يرى في المحور اللاتيني مع
روسيا والصين خطا جديدا للقوه ولذلك
الولايات المتحده تحاول تدارك الاخطاء
فكمارس الفائت مثلا كافات واشنطن انتقاد
الرئيس الكولومبي ايفاندوكي للحرب الروسيه
عبر تصنيفه حليفه الرئيسيه من خارجته لكن
حدث ما احرج واشنطن دبلوماسيه في اغسطس
جديد لكولومبي
قبل ايام رفض تقديم اسلحه اوكرانيا
من الولايات المتحده حل مشكله الص الاسلحه
الروسيه التي لدينا وتسليمها اليهم ليتم
نقلها الى اوكرانيا قلت لهم ان دستورنا
ينص على السياسه السلام في الساحه الدوليه
ستبقى هذه الخرده المعدنيه في كولومبيا
ولن يسلم الاسلحه الروسيه حتى يتمكنوا من
نقلها الى اوكرانيا لمواصله الحرب
واشنطن وتحديدا في عهد ترامب الكونغرس
ناقشه الامر ميرارا 22 دوله اللاتينيه
وكربيه جزءا من مبادره الحزام والطريق
التغلغل الاقتصادي كبير مع نفودا عسكري
ايضا الصين اقامه منتدى دفاعيا مع دول
امريكا اللاتينيه ومن فقط الكاريبي وقدمت
دورات عسكريه كما تدرب افراد الجيش الصيني
على حروب الادغال في القاره اللاتينيه
اسواق السلاح جديد تقيمها الصين وفي
الارجنتين مثال كانت تتفاوض مع بكين على
شراء مقاتلات جي اف 17 لكنها تراجعت نهايه
العام الماضي وما هو
المقابلته اخرى لتحديث القوات الجويه
الارجنتينيه امر لم يحدث
بريطانيا
هي الاخرى على الارجنتين من اجل بناء
قاعده بح في عشوايه باقليم ياتيرا ديلفو
الى جانب محطه فضائيه بنيت بالفعل باداره
عسكرينا صينيين